if took months of often acrimonious
debate but in the end Brazilian Senate
passed a sweeping overhaul of the
country's pension system senators voted
60 to 19 in favor of the main text of
the reform delivering a major victory
for President Jerry Paulson ro who
considered it his keystone economic
proposal I want to compliment the entire
ministerial team the Senate of the
Republic the National Congress and the
Chamber of Deputies it's one of the most
difficult issues but at the same time
the most important for Brazil Brazilian
governments have failed to pass pension
reform for decades the bill promises to
reduce the country's huge social
security deficit saving the Treasury
almost two hundred billion dollars over
the next decade it raises the minimum
retirement age and increases worker
contributions among other painful
measures hello oh my head farmer Qi is
is yield it will be a reform that will
demand that the worker works for longer
pays more for longer retires later and
certainly earns less than they deserve
this is the realities why did we approve
it because there is no other option like
you've reached rock bottom on Tuesday
Brazilian stock markets hit an all-time
high on the expectation of the news
believing the measure will boost
investor and business confidence but it
could spark protests on the streets as
it did back in July when it passed a
lower house with many Brazilian worried
about across-the-board cuts to social
programs and afterward how much to raise
the minimum age it's natural but I don't
think it's proportional to Brazilian
life expectancy in my case for example I
don't know if I will be able to retire
for president both so narrow this is an
important political victory in an
otherwise controversial tenure and it
opens the door to his next target and
overhaul of Brazil's convoluted tax
system
and ramp et al Jazeera